the people's elbow dropped by Biz from the
top rope boom people's elbow four out of
10 hello everybody and welcome to the first in
studio edition of The Jackie Redmond show we've
got quite the guest list for you let me tell you
we're going to be hanging out with WWE Superstar
and noted Chicago Blackhawks fan CM Punk plus
a WWE super fan who also happens to be an NHL
Legend and we're catching up with a special and
secret for now guest oh and I'm also going to
give you my thoughts on the heart trophy race
no big deal but we can really only start this
show in one place and that's backstage at Monday
Night Raw with the cult of personality himself
CM Punk many know him as the best in the world
I know him as a DieHard Chicago Blackhawks fan
WWE Superstar CM Punk thank you for doing this
I appreciate you being one of the first guests
ever on The Jackie Redmond show congratulations
on the show well well deserved uh appreciate uh
a lady who knows her hockey so it's exciting to
be here and yeah I love the I love how casual
this is yeah I know right we're trying to be cool
here uh on this show but I wanted to have you on
because I think it's well documented that you're
a DieHard Chicago Blackhawks fan what I think a
lot of people don't realize about you is that you
follow the whole league like you are a you are a
fan of the sport well I am a Blackhawks fan I feel
like I've watched more coyote games this year than
I have Blackhawks games how surprised are you by
the yots that says it right there I think right
so surpris like uh we were talk we were talking
off camera about um if I'd ever been to the Bell
Center because you know you need to go to the Bell
Center to see the Canadians play I want to go see
the Coyotes play you want to go to Mullet Arena
yes what if there's like 4,000 people like like
it's an intimate it's a more intimate atmosphere
and now they're actually good so I imagine that
it's even amped up more sounds like a great time
people that I know that have gone to molet Arena
have enjoyed it uh but let's get back to you I am
sorry about the news this week a tough week for
you uh very tough week uh speedy recovery Conor
Bard it's been it's been fun watching him play uh
had to see him skate for the first time in the NHL
so booked a flight to Pittsburgh watch the Hawks
beat the the P I love Pittsburgh so much love
Sydney Crosby and I love them all so much so it
was great to watch the Hawks beat them he got his
first assist and then I watched the home opener I
I I got to go to the United Center to watch that
and that was that was exciting and and Superstar
uh not even in the making like he's really just
been everything he has been advertised to be yeah
yeah it's pretty unbelievable for an 18-year-old
to come into that league with all that pressure
and then everything that's happened over the
course of the season so far and the way that
that he's handled it has has been awesome future
looks bright uh for the Chicago Blackhawks I want
to know what came first for you love of wrestling
or love of hockey I think wrestling because I was
exposed to it first uh just on television you
know um hockey came a little bit later but not
much later because I was fortunate enough to see
a game played at the uh Old Chicago stadium and
that blew my mind and it was just like just the
atmosphere and the physicality and I didn't know
at the time but I truly believe the reason I love
hockey so much is because it's just a microcosm of
life it's like this is our family there's five of
us and this is my little brother and if you touch
him I will I will teach you violence and if I get
in trouble for being violent I go over here for
five minutes and I sit you know and then but life
life goes on you know back on the ice and that's
just I I just fell in love with both wrestling and
Hockey being exposed to him at an early age that
first game that you went to too what was the crowd
like what was the atmosphere like at that first
game that really like pulled you in everybody
always talks about how loud that place was and
I describe it as I remember walking in as a little
kid I I don't know how old I was eight and I could
see the noise that's how loud it was it's like
there's no other way that means way powerful
no other way to describe it and uh just watching
guys skate like you know Dirk Graham Dennis avard
uh oh God love that man and being in this this
crowd with all these people getting crazy where
there three fights in the in the audience wait not
wait wait not players not players no not on the
ice there was I I'm I I wish I could remember what
game I saw I'm pretty sure it was a Minnesota game
so you know there was fights it's noris division
there's fights and you were like these are my
people I've arrived there was there's a guy in
front of me in a business suit like he just came
from work downtown and he got a beer dumped on him
from like next level up and he got up disappeared
I didn't think anything of it and when he came
back he had like uh like toilet paper shoved up
his nose like his lip was bleeding and he just
like sat back down and like watched the game
watch the rest of the game took care of something
and now and I truly I was like I'm with my people
you know sometimes sometimes you got to fight you
know what I mean and I was just like wow I didn't
know this existed this is amazing it sure does and
while we're on the topic of fighting I would not
be a serious journalist if I did not ask for your
expert opinion on Paul bassinet fighting buoy at
the Winter Classic I assume you saw the clips I of
course you saw the clips they're they're viral the
people's elbow dropped by Biz from the top rope
boom uh people's elbow four out of 10 um I mean
just choice just choice of mov I understand safety
being Paramount and everything like that but you
know like I really I would I would like to see
Biz like maybe pick him up yeah you know we can
go real old school and do airplane spins I mean
there was a debt there was a table right there as
well right I mean if you're going to go for it you
should really commit I think oh 100% especially
goon like Biz come on yeah you should have put
them to the table more of you Biz we expected more
of you okay we have talked about this off camera
I'm not sure if you've talked about it in other
interviews but you have like a love of goalies
right huge where why where does that come from
your love ofenders uh because there's something
wrong with me just like there's something wrong
with all the very best goalies you know and I
grew up in an era watching guys like Ron hexall
and to me the goat greatest of all time Patrick
W there has to be something like inherently wrong
with you if you are willing to sit in the crease
and have people like this this inch wide you know
galvanized rubber Puck that's frozen and you
know it's flying at you like 100 miles an hour
and you're like I'm okay with this and people are
in your crease and they're trying to kind of run
you a little bit even though no one ever admits
it it's true yeah yeah I there's there's just I
don't know there's like this kinship I have with
goalies because just that that looks like a a very
hard job a very important job kind of a thankless
job sometimes and a lot of the times could be
the greatest team in the world if you don't got
somebody stopping pucks like how good are you for
the wrestling fans or WWE fans that are watching
I am G to ask Punk a couple of WWE questions later
in the interview but for now this is a hockey show
first it's all hockey this the best thing I can
make fun of you for liking the Leafs it's all he
has done since he has come back to WWE it's it's
it's it's so comforting having Bard because no
matter who supports what team says whatever they
want to me I just go Bard I'm just hoping that
the nander contract is a good one and that the
Leafs can win with four Superstar players locking
up all their money but we'll we'll see you want to
lock up some money on this right now you you want
to make a bet yeah okay what are the details of
the BET then Mr so every so every year for I don't
know how long I've made a monetary bet on the it's
it's always the Cup Final okay fair enough and
it's a lot more fun when I have skin in the game
and I obviously I haven't in quite some time um
you aren't daring to suggest that the Hawks will
make a final before the Leafs oh 100% 100% and and
and Conor Bard uh gets a cup before Conor McDavid
oh do I have to all of I'm just pissing off all of
Canada right now do I have to take both those bets
or can I only take one um well let let's let's
let's Okay Leafs I love where this is going by
the way yeah Le uh I mean Hawks Hawks are in a
final hoist in the cup before the Leafs again
yeah I mean I'm gonna take the bet all right
what what the stipulation of this bet is I mean
you guys can chime in we shook on it uh we got to
figure out what the stakes are money embarrassment
I don't know whatever we'll figure something out
I've been I've been uh in some it's it's always
either a dollar there's been a there's been tattoo
bets whoa oh my gosh oh yeah okay listen I think
I'm going to win this Indian head right here
right right here Hax logo yeah right on my arm
I can't commit to that but if you have ideas for
what the Stak should be of our bet hit us up let
us know on the social media channels we are at
the H I love that we just did that by the way I
had no plans of that that was just an organic
there's no format here ladies and gentlemen
taking over the interview which I love um you're
back in WWE The Royal Rumble is coming up I want
to ask you about your first return to Monday Night
Raw before you got to address the crowd you hadn't
spoken to the WWE Universe yet I saw you that day
you chirped me about being a Leafs fan but before
you went out you know you were all business was
there any part of CM Punk before going out there
on Monday Night Raw that was nervous 100% of CM
Punk was was nervous you know um returning to to
wrestling is one thing returning to WWE is like a
completely different animal you know and I didn't
know how things would go and it's not like I was
off TV for a super long time uh so but you still
as a performer you're still like are they going
to remember me are they you know and and I was
legit like in an arena that had not been kind to
me throughout my career uh first UFC fight was in
that building I didn't even realize that you know
know I ran out of things like bad things like a
lot of bad things have happened to me in this
in this building you know what I mean got beat
up here you know uh but I I I think it was also
like hugely cathartic because I'm very much a guy
who if you ask me if I'm ready I'm going to tell
you no uh because part of the juice is being in
front of the live crowd I'm I'm the old guy on the
ice now we like I can stretch and I can warm up
and I'm not going to be ready until I'm on the ice
the whistle blows and the puck drops now I'm ready
so I need to be in front of the crowd and I need
to see the red light on the camera and then it's
like okay now it's go time all right well Seth
freaking Rollins have to ask about him he has made
it clear that he hates you what do you think is
the main reason that he is so bitter towards you
um
uh because I have been everywhere he has been
and he hasn't been everywhere I've been so we're
probably too similar that's honestly the biggest
thing that I can think of is we're were were very
similar and but the difference is I can talk about
my career and not have to mention him he cannot
talk about his career without mentioning me so
I understand where he's coming from you know I
I I understand uh I think he's always felt like
he's the little brother you know and I've never
tried to treat him that way I've always treated
him like a peer but some people you just can't
reach all right well I am very especially after
what you just said curious to see how this all
shakes out between you and Seth and the issues
that he certainly has made clear that that he
has with you hates me he hates he used the word
hates and he was very serious I mean hate is
it's a strong word Aban Red Wings you know that's
that's going back but you know what they say you
can't have hate without love you can't hate
because hate is such a strong emotion right
they're two were intertwined indifference they're
literally the same thing okay we could have a real
philosophical conversation about this the same
thing but I totally agree and on that note I'm
doing a hard pivot to your Stanley Cup prediction
before we wrap this up gosh I can't not ask you
that it is you know I mean you're really you're
yeah it is but man lot can change a lot can change
uh I predict a Western Conference Final between
uh Vegas and Winnipeg okay love it um heli and the
Jets yeah I mean I I just feel like they're like
all the other Canadian teams though they've been
like up and down and up and down and sometimes
they're consistently good but it's just like
they can't break through in the playoffs so uh
I don't know and then for the East I uh the East
is harder to pick I think it is thinkers think I
mean it's it's weird cuz I don't know I don't know
how they're going to match up either like um I I
could see the Bruins yeah Bruins still got like
to me never count the Bruins to me it's about
goalies right and they got a wicked and I said
that because it's Boston uh they got a wicked
goalie tandem so the East is just I don't know
it seems harder to pick I I liked it when the
I always felt like whoever's coming out of the
West Was going to win the cup and I feel like
for the last I don't know almost 10 years it's
been whoever comes out of the East is winning the
cup all right well I appreciate the prediction I
also appreciate the bet or maybe I don't but I
definitely absolutely 100% appreciate the time
thank you so much for doing this I do appreciate
it anytime we'll do it weekly oh okay don't tempt
me because I will hold you to that CM Punk thank
you so much cheers boom huge shout out to CM Punk
for making time for this show I don't know if
you've heard but he is in very high demand he
is one of the biggest WWE Superstars ever and
honestly when I found out we were going to get
the CM Punk on the show it only felt appropriate
to call up my good friend who has also coached
over a thousand games at the NHL level the one
the only Bruce Buro a WWE super fan Bruce how
the heck are you I feel like we have not chatted
in so long I know it's it seems like well it has
been since last June I think uh when we worked the
the finals together so it it's uh it's great to
be here Jackie it's great to see you great to see
your success going so well and I mean and anytime
I can maybe get an inside scoop I don't know if
I'm going to get it but if I can get an inside
wrestling scoop I'm good to go now to be clear we
haven't spoken on camera since June but we've had
a few phone calls exchanged a few text messages
here and there I want to start with WWE because it
feels like WWE is at as big as ever Bruce I know
you're a huge fan and in the last just handful of
months I mean we've seen the rock state that he
wants to sit at the head of the table we've seen
CM Punk come back and stake his claim wanting
to sort of finish his story to borrow a phrase
from Cody rhods what do you make of what's been
happening in WWE over the last few months I just
think they're trying to make it such a surprise
for everybody because so many big names are being
intertwined in the storylines right now you just
never know like when I'm watching it whether it's
Friday night or Monday night H and I'm sitting
there going okay um what's GNA happen at the end
of the show what's G to happen at the start of
the show those are the things that in the 90s
um the storylines from Stone Cold and Bret Hart
and all those those were the things that made it
I think the story lines are getting right back to
that right now so anything can happen in the next
couple weeks I'm looking looking forward to the
surprises yeah we got the RO Rumble right around
the corner and for viewers who are watching that
might not know what that is it's 30 entrance they
have to toss each other over the top rope Last
Man Standing uh in the ring uh gets a shot at
whatever Championship he wants at WrestleMania
so it's a lot at stake for the superstars that
compete in it I want to know who you want to see
in the Royal Rumble well you know what for me The
Only Name that really is uh hasn't been mentioned
one way or the other I mean is Brock Lesnar and
I'd like to see him all of a sudden as I remember
when Cena was announced as the 30th coming out or
something if all of a sudden he was the 26th or
27th guy in the rumble I think the he would get
the biggest pop ever and I think it would be
really cool to see him so when you're at home
watching Mond Night Raw or Friday Night Smackdown
and something big like that happens you know Brock
Lesnar shows up or I mean the rock just showed up
out of nowhere on on on day one uh of WWE Raw like
how does Bruce Buro pop like what happens in your
house when something that you love happens it's
just a big whoa that was surprising type thing
and like I mean I get more geeked up when the
crowd gets gets going and and when when Rock said
the other night that uh he's coming after the head
of the table to watch the fans uh sort of erupt
that's what makes me happy well you know what it's
like to be at the center of a crowd rooting you on
and cheering for you I mean Bruce there it is will
live in infamy uh I think forever for the rest of
time I mean that was epic what happened while you
were in Vancouver they really got behind you and
then we see a WWE crowd chanting Bruce there it
is in Vancouver uh when Kevin Owens was out
there what was your reaction into that were
you surprised and have you talked to Kevin Owens
about all of that well I was shocked to be quite
honest that that I'm watching Vancouver and uh
or watching it come from V Vancouver and you
hear Bruce there it is Bruce there it is and I
start laughing and and telling my wife that it's
hilarious I get right on the phone right away and
I start texting Kevin Kevin did you hear that and
I mean he texted me back as soon as he could and
said yeah and he said there was signs here too so
I said wow that's awesome that was cool stuff all
right I'm going to ask you a hard question now if
you had to pick only one guy that you could root
for here in the leadup to WrestleMania because it
is WrestleMania season here Cody rhods CM Punk or
you know maybe the rock if the rock reappears at
some point before Manny you can only root for one
who are you rooting for to see accomplish their
current goals I I'm not the hugest Cody rhods fan
and everybody loves him and I know but I mean I
like other guys different uh and I haven't seen
CM Punk wrestle yet he's talks a great fight so
I don't know if I want him but to see the rock if
he was committed to wrestling for a period of time
I would love to see him fight Roman Reigns to the
head of the table but then he'd have to stay he'd
have to stay in wrestling cuz I mean you can't
just win that thing and then leave I mean you
got you got to show the wrestling fans that you're
ready to to be the head of the table and not just
sit at the table have a meal and leave you got to
stay for multiple courses multiple dinner dates
if you want to sit at the head of the table I get
it but you know people are going to be like Bruce
what's your beef with Cody rhods but we will leave
that discussion for maybe your next appearance uh
on the Jackie Redmond show because I do want to
pick your brain about hockey as well right we
talk about the Royal Rumble people love it it's
one of the most popular ples of the year because
of the surprises and this year in the NHL I mean
we have had no shortage of surprises what has been
the biggest surprise to you uh this season so far
oh well you know what right now I got to believe
is um and I looked at these numbers the other
day uh the winter Pig Jets have went 29 games
in a row with allowing three goals or less I find
that phenomenal that means the consisten of this
team is they're there for real so I mean that's
one of the many storylines to me the success of
them and a lot of it has happened after Connors
Kurt Connor went out with an injury and he was
their best player so I mean Rick bonus by the way
uh same age as me an older coach has gotten this
has gotten this team going and and so I really
like what they've done and I I really think it's
a great surprise I'll be honest the Vancouver
Canucks um still going strong it's not a surprise
that their best players are their best players
it's a surprise that they're being as consistent
as they are but I I always knew Thatcher Demco
was one of the best goalies in the NHL and he's
certainly proving it this year I want to hear what
you have to say about the Toronto M beliefs I mean
William neander just signed that massive deal
115 per what what do you make of the deal and
what do you make of the Leafs as a whole so far
this season well up until Christmas time I mean
I was not worried but saying well they're they're
not winning like I mean um very easily every game
seemed to go to uh overtime or every game was
a come from behind game I mean the I think the
best thing that happened to them is the last three
games they they beat La in LA and that was great
A great win because I think La is a really good
team but then beating Anaheim San Jose and then
coming back to San Jose uh at home tonight I think
they're getting a real footing of how good they
can be it's interesting and it's nice to see some
Canadian teams really in the mix this season and
making a push to maybe contend for a Stanley Cup
uh in April I'm talking about MVP on this show and
what it means to be an MVP in hockey I'm curious
your thoughts on you know what defines the most
valuable player in the NHL not best player in the
NHL but most valuable and and who you think fits
the bill this year in that category if I I had
to say a Most Valuable Player this year right
now would to me would be Nathan McKinnon I think
in Colorado he's done everything the team is has
played well but they've had some real lapses but
the consistency of Nathan McKinnon I think he's
scored 21 straight home games right now um you
know I mean that's there's only been four guys
that have done that and I think Gretzky's done it
twice and who are the other guys I was like Bobby
or philis pazo not bad compan to keep in yeah you
know so I mean I think he is that straw on that
team that without him boy they'd be a completely
different team now I know there's other teams that
have done great but I think without him they'd
be in trouble yeah I I mean when you're putting
up basically two points a game over a five six
week stretch I mean that's McDavid territory for
Nathan McKinnon so he absolutely has to be in the
conversation for me we're not really at the full
halfway point yet but who who would your like
top three legit Stanley Cup contenders be like
which three teams do you think right now have the
best shot at winning it all wow that's a it's a
great question um and you know what with me it
seems to change all the time uh uh like I mean
if you're asking me right now who's the best team
right now is Winnipeg and Vancouver are the two
best teams do I think they'll be there at the
end when everything and I've I've been in this
situation where it really starts to get ramped up
and it's really hard to stay great the whole year
and I think in February and March the teams that
you expect to be great usually end up being great
because they have to be great and but because I
think the Rangers are going to be there I think
they've got that kind of team Florida went to
the finals last year they're they're playing
great again I've always loved Vegas I mean even
though they're only playing very average right
now I think they're one of those teams that after
the All-Star break will say okay now we know what
we have to do let's get going and they'll be good
and is this the year of the leaf I think if they
get a go tender it could be but I mean until
they do still think Bruce yeah you know what
though and I don't know if any of these guys can
fit anybody under the cap but I do know that no
matter what if uh like I've seen Vegas at a cap at
90 million and they still get icon so they find a
way I've seen um Chicago when they had their great
teams they still found a way to get another guy
under if there's a will there's a way these guys
are so smart that the capologist they find ways
to get people in so if you want a player at some
point whether you're giving away bonus money for
next year and whatever they're not worried about
that if you've got a chance to win the cup they're
going to get the guy they want find a way and by
the way not enough people are giving enough credit
to the Florida Panthers for the first half of
their season considering the way that they started
the year with multiple important injuries uh to
some of their key players but Bruce you're one of
myy players I love talking to you you always make
time for me I have so much respect and admiration
for you you are truly the absolute best so thank
you for coming on the show I could not think of a
better person to have on this episode so thank you
so much what you know what I appreciate it Jackie
and I can't wait to um see you in person maybe
this week at the NHL network but uh uh let's uh
let's continue this I love chatting with you off
and on and see and getting the Scoops so you keep
it going Bruce bu one of the best ever I would say
one of the most incredible just human beings that
I've ever had the chance to work with so thanks
Gabby uh I appreciate you so much thanks Jackie
all right so we've heard Bruce's thoughts on the
heart trophy race but what does it mean to truly
be an MVP anyways I mean does your team have to
make the playoffs to be in consideration and and
if not how far out of the race can you be is it
about impact or production being the most talented
player or being the most complete player how do
we quantify it it's a fascinating topic because
the answer to those questions are rarely if ever
completely clear I mean I found myself on opposite
sides of these arguments many times and yes I am
calling myself a hypocrite context matters but
the context is always changing which brings us to
this season who is the heart trophy front runner
is it the league leader in points as of today
Nikita kov I mean he's factored in on 5050 % of
Tampa's goals this season yeah 50 the bullets
might be in the basement without cooch but how
about Nathan McKinnon I mean he certainly deserves
to be in the conversation the dude has been a man
possessed putting up over two points per game
for the last month that's McDavid territory
Nate Dog means business we can't forget about
Connor McDavid though right he is the consensus
best player in the world but we already have an
award for being the best ever since mcdavid's
gotten healthy though the Oilers have been so
much better in fact McDavid has gone from 503rd
in points to the top five that's honestly so good
it's dumb the Oilers are hot right now but we also
know what they look like when the goalie can't
stop a puck Stuart Skinner and his increasing
save percentage might be more valuable to Edmonton
this season than anything else I said what I said
and the really interesting one for me anyways
is 36-year-old Sydney Crosby one of the great
allaround players ever and having what I consider
to be an MVP worthy season on the back end of his
career there's just one problem he's not leading
the league or even top five in any major offensive
category he is however first in faceoffs taken
and faceoffs won he continues to be one of the
top producers at 5 on five and he's on Pace for
a career high in plus minus yeah that's right it
does matter to an extent especially when you're
on a mediocre team his 200 foot complete game
is undeniable and he is literally dragging the
Penguins into this race Pittsburgh doesn't have
much but they do have one of the most complete
players in the world even at 36 so what are we
to do with Sid how does Crosby's value to the
Penguins compared to McKinnon or maybe our tamy
panarin's value on their objectively more talented
and competitive squads sometimes it feels like an
impossible question but I digress the point
is I've rambled on and on here and heav even
mentioned Pastak didn't really mention the bread
man Austin Matthews or the always underappreciated
a Kopitar the race is real and it ain't even close
to over which is great for us cuz it means we're
going to fight about it all the way till the end
of the season for my money the top three heart
Trophy candidates right now are Nathan McKinnon
Nikita cro and Sydney Crosby let's say you can't
wait to fight about it well this is a segment we
are calling catching up with the commish and yes
he has in fact agreed to this Gary bman thank you
for doing this great to be with you happy New Year
see I say happy New Year this late into January
as well because I haven't seen you yet so to me
it's only fitting that we wish each other a good
year Well year just started it's only been a few
days say it louder Gary say it louder I I think
you can say happy New Year all January as long as
you're not repeating it to the same people over
and over by June it gets a little old I'll even
say February and we can agree on that but this
is a big month for you because coming up at the
end of the month you are going to hit quite a
milestone you are going to become the longest
tenured chief executive in North American Sports
which is wild and to put that into perspective for
people at home that means that 59% of players that
have ever played in The National Hockey League
will have had you as their commissioner you got to
ask them how they feel about that thank you for uh
making me feel old that was not my intention my
intention was to make you feel accomplished sir
but uh you know just does that does a stat like
that Amaze even you it's one that's almost hard
to comprehend yeah almost like being seven years
old like you know it's it's not something you ever
really think about and then there it is uh but
it's always been not just the joy but an honor to
do what I get to do and you can't do what you do
for as long as you have and been as successful as
you have been without you know Peaks and valleys
right so I'll I'll ask only Peaks okay I'm sorry
it's you're right you know what my bad what what
am I thinking you you appreciate the Peaks because
of the Val listen any anything you do doesn't have
a consistent upward trajectory there are always
going to be challenges which I try to make into
opportunities uh but at the end of the day we've
been growing the game is stronger both on and off
the ice our competitive balance is extraordinary
we have the best athletes and the best fans in the
world so it's really just energizing to be a part
of this absolutely is there is there anything that
you're most proud of no I don't do that I mean you
know that in in your line of work yes you focus
on the one thing but but this is to do what I do
it's a team effort I had incredible support
and have incredible support by ownership we
have enormously talented dedicated people at the
league office and at the clubs and as I said our
players are Sensational on and off the ice there's
there nothing in sports like what we have as an
ecosystem and so you know for me it's really about
what we've all been doing together to be part of
this great game spoken like a like a true leader
so I will spin it to you this way what's the
hardest secret you've had to keep and by secret I
mean like if I tell you it won't be a secret well
no no this is why this is why I'm explaining my
friend okay so there's a lot of announcements that
you get to make right and they're all exciting
sometimes they pertain to the Winter Classic where
all-star weekend is going to be different things
right what has been the hardest like announcement
that you've had to keep close to the vest you
couldn't tell anyone it was going to happen until
a certain time and it was the hardest one not to
tell people about that's a great question and I've
never been asked that before I I suppose when it
comes to either an ownership change or when we're
going to do an expansion uh and and where it is or
where we are when we've had collective bargaining
I mean again it's never just one thing um and we
try not to keep too many Secrets if if anything
uh particularly with the clubs and publicly we
try to be transparent okay because we want our
fans and everybody associated with the game to
feel the connection to the game and and to to
have that connection you want to feel a part of
what's going on so what you're saying is when
you knew Vegas was getting a team it was exciting
except there probably wasn't a well-kept secret
because when we went out there for the press
conference everybody knew why we were there I
know we got too many insiders in this sport you
know they're good at they're good at doing their
jobs to say the very least about that I want to
get your thoughts on the pwl because it is off to
a sensational start they are packing Arenas and
you know as someone who sits here as a female
who grew up loving hockey and playing hockey and
and wanting to be around it forever you know I
have my name up there you know with your league
and I I cannot express my gratitude for that so
you have always been someone that I know supports
women in this business just two-way street well I
really do appreciate it um what have you made of
this start pwhl well I think we've been very clear
over the years that as long as organizationally
women's hockey was fragmented it was never really
going to get off the ground and and the Walters
Group with Billy Jean King finally got every
everybody to come together and we've been working
very closely with the pwl as particularly in the
startup phase where we have obviously a lot more
infrastructure than they do and we've been helping
them to the extent they want it uh deal with the
issues that they needed to deal with to get off
the ground I think they're off to a great start
I think it's wonderful to see they're going to
be part of Allstar Weekend uh and we want to use
our platforms to help raise the profile a because
it's good for women and girls I have and young
boys I yes but I have two two daughters adults
uh I have five granddaughters with a sixth on
the way and so at the end of the day I think
it's great for sports it's great for women it's
great for young people uh and we're happy to be
supportive yeah it's it really is exciting to
see the ripple effect of That League sort of
taking off and and and be supported in the way
that they've been supported by the NHL by people
that love h in general and the media as well and
the story came out about some board members for
that League coming to you seeking advice and it
was you that suggested hey Ottawa is probably a
place that you should think about why was Ottawa
you know one of the teams that you suggested to
the pwhl because their opener was outrageous
it Ottawa has great Sports particularly great
hockey fans it's the nation's capital I felt
that based on the priority of markets they were
looking at I said I think it would be good for
the league and its prominence to be in Ottawa
and to have that kind of profile and support and
uh you know I only made it as a suggestion but I
guess it resonated and and I guess it was an okay
suggestion yeah it appears that that is the case
uh you know in the pwhl there I want to ask you
some fun questions now because this is what this
show is about passion for the game weren't these
fun yeah you're always fun Gary but uh you know
the pwhl they're experimenting with some some
things you know a lot of people talking about
the short-handed goal ends the power play I won't
ask you if the NHL is ever going to think about
that but I am curious what the strangest or most
random uh Game Change suggested suggestion you've
received whether a fan a friend a family just
anybody well actually the the one that comes
to mind was a mistake for a couple of years
and that was the zero tolerance foot in the
creek when we were basically calling back goals we
shouldn't have been calling back uh and uh my in
my instinct when we implemented the rule was I'm
not sure this was a great idea sure so now now
when when we have rule change suggestions I tend
to be a little more resistant because there are
always repercussions and unintended consequences
that you have to deal with and be prepared for
yeah and some that there's no way to see some of
those Ripple effects until they actually happen
I would imagine hopefully if you're going to do
a rule change and Rule changes should be taken
very seriously uh you hopefully think through
all of the consequences unintended or otherwise
absolutely you know we had a Chicago Blackhawks
Die Hard fan on earlier WWE Superstar CM Punk uh
was on the show sharing his Love of the Game have
you ever watched WWE do you ever have a wrestling
phase as a kid or anything like that when when I
was a a lot lot younger and I was a kid uh and it
used to be on I think Saturday nights on over the
a television I would watch it but but not that I I
do remember when my son who's now almost 40 uh was
either six or seven he was very much into it and
we were having the discussion about whether or not
it was real and and and I remember he's he asked
me to take him to a match and I did and after 5
minutes he pointed to what was going on and said
see well listen I love that that you actually
you've been to a show and you've seen kind of
the production and the performance and and the
entertainment impressive that is WWE it is uh
it's quite a Show CM Punk is a massive fan I'm
curious like who is the most interesting person
that you've met through hockey I'm sure you've
met wrestlers you've met celebrities rappers
politicians I'm sure I've met presidents okay
I met Queen Elizabeth what and that that was
pretty cool because of all the people I've met she
was at it longer than anybody else uh it was it
was on I think it was her 50th Jubilee when she
went through Canada and she actually attended a
Vancouver Canucks San Jose Sharks exhibition game
and dropped the puck what did you guys talk about
well it was a brief conversation because you you
you have to let the uh Royal Family do the primary
uh Focus uh but it was it was really about the
game well the reason I bring up CM Punk as well
is because in wrestling they say if you're get
as long as you're getting cheered or booed you're
doing everything right and you know a little I
feel the same way about that Sil silence means
they don't care and that's not a good thing
exactly you only boo when you're passionate
about something but with you it's you know it's a
fascinating thing because you've you've embraced
right and it's kind of become I get booed I mean
once in a while but it's become this like this
tradition that I think at we're at the point
now where people boo they don't even know why
they're booing they just know that it's what you
do and it's not limited to me other Commissioners
get booed politicians get booed it's the world we
live in but the most important thing and you hit
it is people are feeling a connection a response
and if they want a boo that's better than sitting
on their hands when have you you always had that
perspective or when did you start to lean into it
because we've seen you make jokes about it at
drafts and certain things my attitude in doing
this job was I would never be as good or as bad
as the world said right you just have to do what
you think is right do your homework try your
best do your decisions for the right reasons
and that's how you get a good night's sleep all
right we're going to wrap this up with some quick
rapid fire personality questions is that okay
with you I don't think I have a choice so oh
you absolutely have a choice but I'm glad that
you're gonna play the game all right uh who is
the most famous person in your phone off the top
of your head uh the most famous person on my phone
uh you know what it it's hard to say because I've
met a lot of great people do you have Snoop Dog
in your phone yeah I do yeah I knew it I KN I was
like this guy has Snoop Dog in his phone I would
immediately uh be going there big but last night
last night I was at the ranger Vancouver game and
they showed uh uh Henrik list on the board yeah
I texted him and said that was a great reaction
Keenan Thompson was there I texted him you know as
we were there uh so you know it's hard to choose
when you have so many well I don't want to name
drop but but the fact is you do get a lot of to
meet a lot of interesting people are you or any
of your grandkids swifties uh yes okay have you
been to the ays tour the I wasn't but my uh my
daughter my daughter-in-law and my my daughters
my daughter-in-law and my granddaughter my oldest
granddaughter were there when they played at metti
when she played at my life amazing great great
she loves that venue Taylor Swift yeah no and
she puts on quite a show I actually was at a
concert must have been a tour 15 or so years
ago I I have my my wife and my youngest daughter
who then was a teenager were at a concert and I
caught up to them there H so you're you're
a bit of a Swifty mild mildly mildly mildly
so what's the best piece of advice you've ever
been given um work hard make decisions for the
right reasons and be transparent and honest with
people all right biggest surprise this season in
the NHL for you from a hockey standpoint team
player whatever you want you know it's really
more what we're seeing is incredible games a lot
of come you know something like 45% of our games
are come from behind victories uh our competitive
balance is extraordinary I think it's the best in
sports our games are fast skillful and most
of all entertaining I forgot I lied one more
where's the next one or classic I'm not ready to
make that that's one of those secrets that I'm
keeping you and your secrets no I'm just kidding
Gary honestly I really appreciate apprciate the
time sitting down and doing this interview I know
I don't always ask the most uh common questions
but I try to have fun and I do appreciate that
you put up with it and that you're letting me
have this show I I really means a lot to me great
to be with you and thanks for all you do to cover
our game well I love the game so that's where
it all comes from H we are out of time with the
commish we're hoping we're going to rope him back
we think uh in a couple of weeks to catch up down
the road but I appreciate the time thank you to
everybody for watching thank you to Bruce budro
thank you to cm pun appreciate your time and we
will see you next week for episode 3 thanks for
watching